[Music]
The Goonies never say die Josh GAD
reunited the entire cast of the 80s
classic even producer Steven Spielberg
GAD pulled everyone together to raise
money for the center of disaster
philanthropy which helps those suffering
from the köppen 19 pandemic the special
event did not disappoint and ET is
bringing you 6 things we learned from
the heartwarming reunion number one the
cast can still nail their classic lines
I can't tell if it's an ace sharp or if
it's a b-flat d-flat you know what this
one this one right here this was my wish
my I dream and it didn't come true so
I'm taking it back
number two the actor who portrayed
lovable goofball chunk had a major
blow-up the one person who's no longer
an actor looks most like an actor right
now how is it that chunk is more fit
than any of us now thank you thank you
key my brother key that's very kind yes
it is true I did go from chunk to the
hunk that you now see in front of you
number three the ensemble of child
actors tested the patience of iconic
director Richard Donner on the set my
best memory I have to say didn't happen
during the shooting in the movie it
happened after the movie was over
everyone we cast was high-energy and
after a while it kind of started working
on dick sort of tear him apart a piece
of the time it is the most difficult
thing I ever thought I was gonna get
into I never anticipated what its gonna
be like
number four tons of celebrities would
stop by Steven do you remember when
Harrison came to this set
Harrison Ford visited the set of The
Goonies what didn't Clint came on the
set and he watched for about 15 minutes
and came over to me and he said did you
ever think about going back to acting
number 5 Spielberg said there are no
plans for a sequel anytime soon
but he did provide us with a pretty good
explanation Kristin dick and I and
Lauren have had a lot of conversations
about it and every couple of years we
come up with an idea but then it doesn't
hold water I mean we the problem is the
bar that all of you raised on this genre
I don't think we've really successfully
been able to find an idea that is better
than the Goonies that we all made in the
80s so until we do people are just gonna
have to look at this 100 times and
number 6
moderator Josh GAD is clearly a bonafide
Goonies superfan in 1985 the movie was
released that would forever changed the
course of my life most importantly on
that fateful day I learned four words
that would forever change the course of
my young life Goonies never say die down
here it's our time it's our time down
here that's all over the minute we ride
up Troy's bucket
[Music]